derek is an Iowa
hi Derek welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas what's
going on Dave loving it how can I help
ya so my wife is 29 I'm 28
we've been in steps four five and six
the Lannisters
retirement along the way a year ago we
moving into a new house a passion that
her and I have is fixing up the house
and sleeping and we found a house we'd
like and so we worked it personally as
an investment but also as I said for a
passion of ours my question is the money
that we invest everything into that
house is that included in the 15% on
step four or is it not considered step
four since it's not a dedicated
retirement fund I would use I wouldn't
use it in my baby step four I would do
that and in addition to that I'd fix up
the house as a sighing the point is
save for retirement okay and if you were
to steadily fix up houses and flip them
fix up houses and flip them and every
time you move into it
the only thing you've built for
retirement is your home yeah and so it
doesn't give you any money to eat with
which we do won't get your home paid off
we do once you get you into a nice home
by the time you get to retirement and
you got 40 years to pull this off
but-but-but it's not really gonna turn
into cash you used to buy food and
travel to wonderful places when you're
65 years old it's just going into a
better house each time agreed yep yep so
for that reason I probably would stick
with a traditional baby step forward and
do my fix up out of pocket out of my
budget but you know if you if you dial
it back as long as you've got your head
on screwed on and you don't say never
save for retirement because you got this
house scheme going that would be a bad
idea I agreed I
you wouldn't do that and one
conversation piece we had was maybe
darling back instead of fully invested
my rock may be taken a couple green on
that just this year and then it since
you're positive trophy maybe you just
refunded it then yeah just so we kind of
have a little bit nicer posting area I'm
just just quality of life within our you
know the house that we pop yeah and cuz
you know renovating a house you live in
sucks it's hard yeah and so you want to
get some of those big things the dusty
things out of the way but yeah I just I
think the point is you've got to be very
very intentional and the beauty of the
baby steps is the more I become like
legalistic about them and holds you to
them the more likely you are to create
the life that you're trying to create
and so you know if you do that stuff the
good news is you're kind of having this
feeling like that like you're breaking a
rule or something right yeah yeah that's
why we wanted to call it you know and so
that's going to make you go right back
to the right thing as soon as you can so
it's not the end of the world but I mean
I think job one the optimal thing would
be to just cash flow out of your budget
your repairs while you're putting
fifteen percent in retirement and I
think you're going to have a really
wonderful result from having done that
but I I don't know you know what the
level of repairs are what you're facing
and you know if you turn it back for a
little while and then you turn it back
up and it's not gonna kill you I'm going
to kill you